نحن نطلق ثلاثة أجهزة جديدة الآن ، لذا فقد
أعدت تصميم بوابة بوابة
صغيرة مقاس 10 بوصات مقاس 8 بوصات وتلفزيون المدخل الذي يتم
إرفاقه بأكبر شاشة في
منزلك وقد تم تصميمهما
لمنحنا نفس تجربة البوابة الرائعة ولكن الآن
في  سعر مخفض إلى حد كبير بحيث يكون 179 دولارًا للشاشة
مقاس 10 بوصات و 149 دولارًا لبوابة التلفزيون و 129
دولارًا للبوابة الصغيرة ، لذا ما نوع
البيانات التي تجمعها البوابة
بشكل أساسي كجهاز
مثل الهاتف تمامًا ، ومن ثم فهي تدير برنامج messenger
تمامًا مثل هاتفك  يدير الهاتف برنامج messenger بالنسبة
لنا ، فإن أهم البيانات التي نفكر
فيها في هذا المنتج هي فهم كيفية
استخدام الأشخاص لدينا له لإجراء مكالمات فيديو
، وهل يستخدمونه لمشاهدة المحتوى
وهذا يساعدنا على فهم ما يجب التركيز
عليه للتكرارات المستقبلية لـ
منتج وهو عام نسبيًا ، أعتقد أن
الفئة الأكثر حساسية من البيانات التي
يفكر فيها الناس هذه الأيام هي
كيفية استخدام
التفاعلات الصوتية والتفاعلات الصوتية هي شيء
وضعنا الكثير من الطاقة في صنعه.  تأكد من أننا
نمنح المستخدمين تحكمًا ، لذلك ظهرت تقارير مؤخرًا تفيد
بأن Facebook قد استأجر بعض
المقاولين للاستماع إلى
المحادثات التي تمت من خلال برنامج
messenger و Messenger ونسخها ، حيث يساعد Messenger على تشغيل
البوابة ، هل يمكنك
أن تطمئن مشاهدينا وقرائنا إلى أن Facebook لا
يستمع إلى المحادثات الخاصة ،
نعم  عندما يكون الميكروفون نشطًا ، فإن هذا
الجهاز مثل العديد من الأجهزة في
الفئة يستمع إلى كلمة التنبيه يا
بوابة وعندما يسمع
تسجيلًا صوتيًا قصيرًا ويتم إنشاء نص
وإرساله إلى الخوادم التي قد تتم
مراجعتها من قبل فريق من المراجعين المدربين
إلى  تحسين دقة
الخدمات الصوتية للجميع
الآن حتى منذ إطلاق الإصدار الأول من
البوابة ، يمكن للأشخاص مراجعة
تفاعلاتهم الصوتية
وحذفها والآن أضفنا القدرة
على إيقاف تشغيل التخزين تمامًا ، لذا إذا قام الأشخاص
بإيقاف التخزين ، فهذا يعني أن
لا يتم تخزين التسجيلات الصوتية والنسخ الصوتية في الخادم
ولا تتم مراجعتها أبدًا وبالطبع t  مرحبًا ، يمكنهم
الوصول إلى هؤلاء في أي وقت سواء على
الجهاز نفسه أو في سجل نشاط facebook ،
ولكن إذا اختاروا ذلك ، فمن
الناحية النظرية يمكن لشخص ما أن يكتب
أو يستمع إلى المحادثة ، نعم
نريد أن نقدم للناس أفضل
تجربة ممكنة و  مع المساعدة ،
فإن الطريقة التي يتم تحسينها
للجميع هي من خلال وجود بائعين مدربين
في بيئات آمنة للغاية والذين هم
خبراء في ما يفعلونه للمساعدة في تحسين
عملية النسخ والتشفير ، ما
هو نوع من الرؤية للخطة طويلة المدى
هنا ، هذا هو Facebook لذلك نحن  ترغب في
طرح المنتجات في السوق ثم معرفة
كيفية استجابة الأشخاص لها ، كما تعلم ، كنا
متحمسين جدًا للاستجابة
من الجيل الأول من البوابة
التي استخدمناها لإعلام الجيل الحالي
ولدينا
بعض التجارب الجديدة المثيرة جدًا
هنا  لذا فإن ألعاب الواقع المعزز هي قدرة
شخصين على مكالمة فيديو على ممارسة
الألعاب معًا يشاهدان معًا
هذه الأشياء المثيرة والجديدة وإذا
نماها  يتبنى الأشخاص تلك
المجالات التي قد نستثمرها أكثر
[موسيقى]